[Music]
uh the bear market
and uh if we want to be a sarcastic and
funny we can say scary bear
scary scary bear because the bear market
the stock market's down 20 so he said he
lost 200 000 bucks so he's lost he had a
million dollars it's 401k last caller
probably somewhere in that neighborhood
yeah that makes sense and he hasn't lost
200 000 bucks unless he sold it
uh because there's two two types of
gains there's recognized and realized
recognized as i recognize that my
balance is down but until i sell it i
didn't lock in the lawsuit it doesn't
become reality it's not it is not
realized it's just we're just
recognizing and from tax purposes we use
that terminology accounting purposes but
also is kind of a factual thing that you
know like during the drop of 2008 and
the market went from 13 000 to 6 500 it
went in half it went down 50 percent
people were interviewing warren buffett
mr buffett didn't you just lose 83
billion dollars and he said no i didn't
lose anything i haven't sold anything i
hadn't sold anything i just it's just
riding down and ride it back up and of
course it went down from 6 500 to 13 000
and then back to 39 000 from there three
x above so turns out mr buffett would
that's right the stock market in the
real estate market perspective is what
keeps you from making poor decisions so
when you look at that perspective and go
oh it went back up to 39 percent
probably should have stayed in the
market thirty nine thousand dollars yeah
yeah
when you pan back and you see history it
can calm you down that's a good thing to
do it helps me
um and so let's talk about actual
history and data on bear markets a bear
market is any time that the stock market
goes down more than 20 in value which
we're in the middle of a bear market
since world war ii
post great depression there have been 14
bears
that's a lot of bears yeah
we've got a bear problem so um
and the
average length of a bear market during
those 14 is 13 months and the average
time to recover
back to ground zero back to where it was
before the decrease started
was is about 24 months 26 months 23
months i've read three different
articles so but it's right in there
right around two years
and so
if we go back to the first of the year
which is where we're measuring the
decline from
and you go out two years from january 1
of 22 that'd be january 1 of 24
the average is it will have recovered by
then wow which means that there's a
chance it will cover sooner
and there's a chance it could recover
later that's the average of 14 different
events
and so you've got a lot of
actual data the chances of this one
being drastically different
i don't see that happening well it's not
as extreme as 2008
and of course the more extreme it drops
so far it's not
the more extreme it drops the um
the longer it would take to recover
typically it would unless it just shot
back up due to some kind of a
magical economic pill or something but
you know so here's the story
you're
52 years old
and you're panicking because your
retirement lost 200 000 of your million
i don't know how that guy was i'm making
this up okay
at 54 you'll be back
on average
chance you'll be back by 53
chance you'll be back by 55. the chances
that 65 of you being down based on
historical data are precisely zero
calm your butt down
okay
that's what that says i'm
getting ready to be 62.
uh i'm not going to be using my money
that's in the stock market in my 401 k
or my other mutual fund investments um
maybe ever
unless i used it to buy some real estate
but i mean i uh
so i easily can let it sit there till
death and
uh
but i mean the chances of me
statistically i'm healthy at 62 no zero
medication uh on average moderately good
condition on average uh the actuarial
table say i'm going to live to 90.
okay so i've got 28 years to ride this
out not 28 months
so i'm real comfortable
with putting more in right now while
it's down because it's on sale if you
keep that perspective and you've got a
long-term vision and you know so you pan
back like you said perspective
gives you hope people lose hope when
they lose their perspective
and the joke that we always used was one
of my daughters didn't get asked to the
prom by one of those boys
and that night it was a long night there
was wailing and gnashing of teeth
it was so very sad
and her mother and i were supposed to go
in and comfort her in her moment of
heartbreak but we were having trouble
not laughing in the hallway because it
was so dramatic that it was funny well
because we've been to our 20-year class
reunion and we know when she sees him
then she'll be glad
we have the perspective of time
right we know that is this this
heartbreak is not the end of the world
uh although it is the end of the world
for her at this moment but she does not
have the perspective of time
because she's a newbie can you tell us
which daughter this there's no
not a chance i'm just going to guess it
was wrong
no i i have a great poker face george
i'll never reveal that
it was bad enough that i told the story
to start with that's fair uh but the
point being you lose perspective
if when you lose perspective is a good
chance you lose hope
in order to think that the world is
coming to an end you have to have a
fairly short window that you're looking
at
because there's no long-term window data
that indicates that
only
the panic of the moment
the flavor of the week
here at baskin-robbins
but you know that's that that's what
we're dealing with right yeah and when
you look at the data you know you kind
of get what you're looking for if you're
looking for panic you'll probably find
it in the headlines and you'll probably
find doomsday but if you look at the
charts and the graphs in history and
yeah you live your life by these
principles you can kind of just breathe
easy
the weight's not there when you start
looking for that
you know if you're in bitcoin there is
reason to panic
absolutely i can tell you stories for
days dave the really sad stuff happening
with the crypto bros out there are the
crypto bros are they're hurting they
they were declining or prom let's say
we're gonna
there's the analogy
hey they've been rejected throwing
temperatures no date for the prom
sorry crypto bro no date for the prom
i don't think they're going to prom dave
they're not the type
oh
[Music]
that's sad
we need to like form a support group for
him we should a dave ramsey crypto bro
support group make that happen guys you
know i i would think that one would sign
up maybe one